hi my name's Emma I'm asking food sir
and beauty blogger my name is Shelley
I'm a German fashion and lifestyle
influencer based in London my name is
Sarah I'm a fashion imputs a vintage
store owner and I looked for a
sustainable fashion
you're watching glamour try is the
series where we track the latest future
products and trends
today we are trying out the Schwarzkopf
only love at home hair color and I'm
using the color melted chocolate which I
cabbage trail I've picked the color pick
and tucked and I've gone for the shade
all not mousse since I've been beauty
blogging for over ten years I found out
so many products on the market and one
thing I'm always really looking for is
nourishing ingredients I'm really really
into my skin and I kind of think of my
scalp as an extension of my skin so I'm
always trying to make sure that that's
cared for so I'm really excited that the
only love has a no ammonia no silicone
and then I'll call I have my t-shirt
ready to color my hair it's really
important when you do decide to curl
your hair is to pick the right color for
your skin tone I have a warm skin tone
but I wanted to a slightly darker that's
why I chose the walnut mousse if you
have a look in the back of it you can
see what color you're actually going to
get as a result of coloring your hair
I've got all natural hair and I've not
pulling my hair for five years so I'm
really excited what the results gonna
look like I just wanted a darker to suit
my skin tone and look glossy and shiny
so I've changed and took my pajamas to
color my hair I've got the box I've got
the towel and so let's see what's inside
I love that they use climate neutral
boxes since I've been testing from where
that's over the years okay
more environmentally-friendly I'm just
going to come up out of the box this is
the developer we've got the color cream
the care conditioner afterwards the
instructions I did an allergy of that
test two days ago but obviously I always
read all the instructions before you
color your hair at home and also got the
gloves open up all you do then you're
gonna screw the lid on very touching
give it a shake and you're good to go so
I've just got my towel over my shoulders
so that I don't stay in my pajamas and
I'm going to use petroleum based product
so that I also don't stain my skin put
my gloves on now I'm gonna pick up the
applicator and I've taken the top off
already and I'm just putting a little
bit there down the middle actually
smells very nice it's a lot easier than
I thought it would be to feels like a
little pan possession it's really
rubbing it in just to make sure it's
evenly spread out this is cooking easy
for me which it's great for someone with
a busy lifestyle like Martin just
working full time means I spent most of
my days in the office so I put it
through all the route so now I'm just
gonna take it down and I'm gonna make
sure I've got a good amount all over to
make sure it's really evenly distributed
it's perfect
[Music]
so this is the final look and I love it
it's all one color now which is amazing
and it's so shiny and glossy only love
comes in ten delicious shades you can
match your skin tone I'm really happy
with it I really love the color it's
exactly what I was after I really love
how warm chocolate see the color came
out and feels really smooth and looks
really shiny so I would definitely
recommend only laughs to anyone who has
thin hair like me and is kind of fond of
natural ingredients - it's so freakin
easy to use at home you can make good
use of your time like the colour
develops my hair just feels incredible
it's really smooth it's incredibly shiny
and the color is really really not true
it's absolutely gorgeous if we tried it
do leave a comment below and of course
subscribe to Clement okay
[Music]